ahora que comenzamos nuestro viaje hacia
el mundo de la economía
me pareció prudente comenzar citando a
uno de los economistas más famosos de
todos los tiempos
el filósofo escocés adam smith y él es
el primer economista real como los vemos
actualmente y este es una cita de su
libro la riqueza de las naciones que fue
publicado en 1776 el mismo año que la
declaración de independencia de eeuu y
esta es una de sus citas más famosas
ninguno se propone por lo general
promover el interés público ni sabe
hasta qué punto lo promueve aquí se está
hablando de un actor económico
y cuando dirige la industria de tal
forma que su producto represente el
mayor valor posible se refiere a la
industria controlada por este actor
económico solo piensa en su ganancia
propia pero en este como en muchos otros
casos y esta parte es conducido por una
mano invisible es un término muy famoso
para promover un fin que no entraba en
sus intenciones más no implica mal
alguno para la sociedad que tal fin no
entre a formar parte de sus propósitos
pues al perseguir su propio interés
promueve el de la sociedad de una manera
más efectiva que si esto entrara en sus
designios
esto se refiere a cuando los actores
individuales buscan su beneficio propio
el resultado final no es algo que cada
uno de estos individuos busque por su
cuenta este es un anuncio no bastante
fuerte es de hecho el núcleo del
capitalismo y por eso hago hincapié en
que fue publicado en 1776 el mismo año
de la declaración de independencia de
los estados unidos ya que la
constitución de este país los fundadores
de esta declaración describen ahí lo que
es ser un gobierno democrático y a lo
que tienen derecho sus ciudadanos pero
en los eeuu la experiencia general de
ser un ciudadano estadounidense tiene
bastante influencia de las ideas de adam
smith de estas ideas fundamentales del
capitalismo y éstas se dieron
aproximadamente en la misma época pero
esta idea no siempre es intuitiva el que
actores individuales busquen su
beneficio propio frecuentemente promueve
el de la sociedad de forma más eficaz
que cuando realmente intenta fomentar lo
que cuando se trata de fomentar el
bienestar de la sociedad
creo que adam smith dijera que esto
siempre es bueno el actuar de manera
egoísta o que nunca sea bueno que las
personas piensen en el beneficio de los
demás pero él dice que es frecuentemente
lo que ocurre el interés personal podría
llevar al beneficio común podría llevar
a mejores innovaciones podría llevar a
mejores inversiones podría provocar una
mejor productividad y llevar a un mayor
beneficio una rebanada más grande de
pastel para todos y de hecho en este
enunciado menciona tanto la
macroeconomía como la microeconomía la
micro se refiere a actores o personas
individuales que buscan su propio
interés y macro se refiere al beneficio
de un país en su totalidad así que ahora
los economistas se dividen en estas dos
escuelas o en estos dos temas la
microeconomía
micro economía
economía que tiene que ver con actores
individuales estos pueden ser empresas
pueden ser personas etcétera y también
tenemos la macroeconomía
macroeconomía
que es el estudio de la economía de un
conjunto y aquí pueden darse cuenta con
el prefijo micro se refiere a lo
individual es algo pequeño macro se
refiere a un aspecto mucho más grande
así que para que quede más claro la
microeconomía se refiere a la toma de
decisiones de un actor individual toma d
decisión
de un actor
y puede ser la toma de decisión
la ubicación
ubicación
de recursos
y es de ubicación de recursos escasos en
particular
y hablamos de ciertos recursos en
particular por ejemplo el amor puede ser
un recurso abundante y se puede tener
una cantidad infinita de este recurso
pero recursos que son escasos pueden ser
por ejemplo comida o agua o dinero o
tiempo o mano de obra todos estos son
recursos escasos así que la
microeconomía trata de como las personas
deciden dónde ubicar estos recursos
escasos como deciden en dónde ponerlos y
cómo esto afecta a los precios o los
mercados y todo lo demás
en cambio la macroeconomía estudia el
efecto agregado de millones de
individuos es la economía agregada
o vista en conjunto
d
de millones millones
de actores
se concentra más en cuestiones de
política
qué pasa con los impuestos qué pasa
cuando se aumentan o se bajan estos se
regula o se desregula cómo va a afectar
la proactividad total así que son
preguntas o cuestiones generales
y la tendencia moderna es tratar de
hacer esto algo riguroso así que en
cualquiera de ambos casos se puede
comenzar con estas ideas filosóficas con
esas ideas filosóficas o las ideas
lógicas como lo mencionado por adam
smith ideas básicas sobre cómo las
personas toman decisiones la filosofía
sobre la toma de decisiones sobre la
toma
de decisiones
al menos en el caso de la microeconomía
y podemos hacer algunas suposiciones al
respecto mediante simplificaciones
y esas simplificaciones son
generalizaciones por ejemplo que todas
las personas van a actuar de manera
racional y que todas las personas
tratarán de maximizar su ganancia lo que
no es necesariamente cierto en todas las
ocasiones ya que los seres humanos
pueden comportarse de maneras muy
diferentes así que lo simplificamos para
poder trabajar con ello de manera
matemática
esto es algo valioso puede ayudarnos a
aclarar nuestro pensamiento nos permite
demostrar cosas basadas en nuestras
suposiciones y nos permite visualizar
las cosas de forma matemática con
diagramas y gráficas y así poder
analizar qué es lo que puede ocurrir con
el mercado así que es tremendamente útil
tener este pensamiento riguroso
matemático tener este pensamiento
matemático riguroso pero al mismo tiempo
puede ser un poquito peligroso ya que
estamos haciendo esta enorme
simplificación y a veces la matemática
nos puede llevar a algunas conclusiones
bastante radicales
en las cuales podríamos sentirnos muy
confiados ya que aquí la matemática no
los está demostrando pero como está
basado en suposiciones que podrían estar
mal o podrían estar demasiado
simplificadas podrían no ser relevantes
sobre las conclusiones que llegamos del
tema es importante tomar todo esto con
un grano de sal y la macroeconomía
todavía es más susceptible de este error
en la macroeconomía tomamos estas cosas
que son muy complicadas sobre el
comportamiento de las personas y cómo
reaccionan entre ellas y esto se aplica
a millones de personas así que eso se
vuelve tremendamente complicado pues
tenemos a estos millones de personas que
están interactuando entre sí ya que aquí
estamos hablando de millones
de interacciones
que fundamentalmente son impredecibles y
de estas interacciones que se basan en
suposiciones
hacemos suposiciones de estas
interacciones y con estas suposiciones
tratamos de encontrar modelos
matemáticos
esto nos lleva a la matemática pero es
tremendamente complicado aplicar la
matemática a este tipo de
comportamientos que son impredecibles y
sin embargo estas matemáticas nos
llevarían a algunas conclusiones o
algunas predicciones entonces hay que
tomar esto todavía con mucho más cuidado
y aunque esto es valioso es muy valioso
tener estos modelos matemáticos que sin
duda ayudan para tratar de predecir o
entender algún comportamiento tanto las
conclusiones como suposiciones obtenidas
de este modelo tienen que tomarse
recordando que están basadas en
suposiciones muy generalizadas de cosas
que realmente son impredecibles entonces
ambas hay que tomarlas con un grano de
sal siempre hay que enfocarse en la
intuición general y esa es la parte
importante a aprender de cualquier curso
de economía encontrar el razonamiento de
qué es lo que sucede incluso sin tener
que usar la matemática aquí les dejo con
dos citas estas citas son un poco
curiosas pero de todas maneras se las
quiero compartir ya que son cosas que es
bueno tener en mente
especialmente cuando entramos en
profundidad al detalle matemático
relacionado con la economía este de aquí
es una cita de alfred knopf que fue un
publicista del siglo 20 y dice que una
economista es una persona que enuncia lo
obvio en términos incomprensibles y
supongo que esta parte de incomprensible
se refiere
a la parte matemática de la economía
y esperemos que en este curso de
economía hagamos estos conceptos lo más
comprensibles para ustedes y también
veremos lo valioso de esto y aquí lo
importante es que se enuncia a lo obvio
se anuncian cosas del sentido común se
anuncian cosas obvias y es importante
que siempre tengan en mente esto que se
enuncia lo obvio la intuición de lo que
está sucediendo en la parte matemática
sobre todo cuando la matemática podría
estar errónea debido a mucha
simplificación o suposiciones
incorrectas y aquí tenemos esta otra
cita de lawrence j peter que es muy
famoso por el principio de peter
profesor de una universidad de eeuu y él
dice un economista es un experto que
sabrá mañana porque las cosas que
predijo ayer no ocurrieron hoy y eso es
algo que debemos de tener en mente
siempre que trabajemos en economía
especialmente en macroeconomía ya que la
macroeconomía hay toda clase de
predicciones que cosas son las que
tienen que hacerse mientras exista una
recesión o cuál será el crecimiento
económico del próximo año que provocará
la inflación y mucho
estas predicciones resultan erróneas
incluso muy pocos economistas se ponen
de acuerdo en lo que predicen o
coinciden en las predicciones que hacen
y es muy importante darse cuenta de esto
ya que cuando nos encontramos sumergidos
en la matemática de la economía
pareciera que trabajamos en una ciencia
como si fuera física pero no es una
ciencia exacta es muy susceptible a la
subjetividad y esta subjetividad está
relacionada con las suposiciones que se
realizan